veamos si podemos encontrar el límite
cuando h tiende a cero de cinco veces el
logaritmo de dos más h
menos cinco veces el logaritmo de dos
esto entre h y te voy a dar una pequeña
pista sobre todo porque quiero que pausa
es el vídeo e intentes encontrarlo por
tu cuenta
piensa en las propiedades de las
derivadas especialmente en las derivadas
de funciones logarítmicas en este caso
con base 10 porque recuerdan que cuando
no ponemos una base a quien solamente
escribimos log estamos hablando de base
así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolver esto por tu cuenta bien la
clave aquí es recordar que si tengo a fx
una cierta efe de x y yo quiero ver
cuánto valen f prima que no sea una
cierta
bueno pues efe prima de una cierta am
por definición esto es lo mismo que
tomarme el límite el límite cuando h
tiende a cero cuando h tiende a cero de
quien bueno de f de amas h ok
a esto le quitamos f de a y dividimos
todo entre h dividimos todo esto entre h
así que si observas esto de aquí es muy
parecido solamente que aquí tenemos
estos cincos que nos estorban pero por
suerte podemos factorizar estos cincos
atrás de este límite porque sabemos las
propiedades de los límites
recuerda que si tienes un escalar o un
factor multiplicando la expresión
sabemos por las propiedades de los
límites que en realidad podemos sacarlos
fuera de los mismos límites entonces
vamos a atrapar estos 25 os vamos a
factorizar los
y este que tengo aquí me va a quedar que
esto sería igual a 5 que multiplican
déjame ponerlo con su respectivo color
que multiplica al límite
cuando h tiende a cero de el logaritmo
2 + h
menos el logaritmo de 2
todo esto dividido entre h
ahora podría reconocer esto la siguiente
manera si por ejemplo pensamos que
tenemos a efe de equis y decimos que fx
es igual al logaritmo de x el logaritmo
de x entonces cuánto vale
efe prima de 2 bueno
efe prima de 2 va a ser igual a quien
usando esta misma idea es el límite el
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de el
logaritmo de 2 más
h
- el logaritmo de dos menos el logaritmo
de dos todo esto
/ / h así que si observas esto puedes
reconocer que todo esto que tenemos aquí
todo esto que tenemos aquí es f prima de
efe prima de 2
sí bueno fx es el logaritmo de x
entonces esto es f prima de 2 ahora la
pregunta es cómo podemos encontrar este
límite quienes f prima de x entonces
quienes f prima de x fm prima de x y
bueno no necesitamos usar la definición
del límite de la definición del límite
es un poco complicada para evaluar este
tipo de límites pero lo que sabemos es
cómo sacar la derivada de funciones
logarítmicas entonces f prima de x va a
ser igual a 1 esto entre el logaritmo
natural de la base en este caso nuestra
base es 10 esto que multiplican bueno
que multiplica a x si esto fuera un
logaritmo natural me quedaría uno entre
el logaritmo natural de x x pero el
logaritmo natural de m es simplemente 1
así que me quedaría uno entre x pero si
tienen cualquier otra base deben de
poner el
natural de esa base justo aquí en el
denominador entonces quién sería efe
prima de 2 bueno
efe prima de 2 va a ser igual a 1 esto
dividido a su vez entre el logaritmo
natural de 10 esto que multiplica a 2 ok
de lujo así que toda esta cosa de aquí
la podemos ver de la siguiente manera
esto va a ser igual a 55 y lo podemos
poner acá arriba 5 que a su vez está
dividido entre el logaritmo natural de
todo esto multiplicado por dos
bueno lo puedes ver como 2 por el
logaritmo natural de 10 la clave para
este tipo de ejercicios consiste en
decir bueno permíteme ver si puedo
evaluar este límite y darte cuenta de
que esto se parece mucho a la derivada
de una función logarítmica en especial a
la derivada cuando x es igual a 2
eso sí podemos factorizar estos cincos y
decir bueno esto es la derivada de el
logaritmo de x cuando x es igual a 2 y
nosotros sabemos sacar la derivada de el
logaritmo de x si no saben sacar esta
derivada tenemos videos donde probamos
esto donde sacan la derivada de
logaritmos que su base es distinta a y
bueno ya solamente usamos eso para
realmente sacar la derivada y evaluar
eso en 2 así llegamos a este resultado y
entonces terminamos